- You've got no hope if
you try to pretend to be
Reed Hastings or Mark
Zuckerberg or Bill Gates.
Life's short.
I mean, you know, why or
what are we doing this
where we like, won't have a difference?
We think of ourself like like alchemists.
We take in money and out comes joy.
I would say I've always believed
that a strong mission
statement's really important
and I have to say we've
never succeeded at it.
- He's an American entrepreneur
and philanthropist.
He's the co-founder and CEO of Netflix
and he serves on the board
of directors of Facebook
and a number of other
non-profit organizations.
He has an estimated net worth
of over a billion dollars.
He's Reed Hastings and here is my take
on his top ten rules to success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always, if Reed says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired, as well.
Enjoy!
(swooshes)
(upbeat orchestral music)
- You have to be authentic.
I mean, you've got no hope
if you try to pretend to be
Reed Hastings, or Mark
Zuckerberg, or Bill Gates,
or whoever you want to think
your CEOs are that you've met.
You know, that is crazy.
And you got to really get
comfortable with yourself,
your strengths, and weaknesses.
People are inspired by authenticity
and I'm just surprised how many people
feel like they're acting
and/or try to act.
And you may be a really
quiet person and that's fine.
But if you have that
fierce will, that desire,
for the institution,
the company to be great,
and your own role in that is secondary,
and you authentically express
that in whatever ways you do,
then you'll be greatly accepted, okay?
And so, that's all it
takes, is to be authentic
and not try to be something else
and to fundamentally care at your core
about what's good for the company.
And if everybody knows and you act
in the notion of what's good
as best as your judgement can tell,
what's good for the
company, they will see that
and people will follow you
and they won't be cynical.
It's when you hide things,
it's when you pretend.
If we don't, if we're not creative enough,
if we don't push it hard enough,
we've got to have some failures
and so, we don't really
want to have all hits.
I'm clearly glad the first ones are hits.
But, you know, the sign that you're
right at the edge of chaos,
the edge of creativity,
is that some stuff doesn't work.
- And why do you want to be there?
'Cause networks don't want to be there.
- Life's short.
I mean, you know, why or
what are we doing this
where we like, won't have a difference?
- Atta-boy, right?
- You know?
And so it's an aid.
It's wanting to push the edge,
to create something that really,
the people are proud
of and that they enjoy.
We collect this year about eight
billion dollars of customers' money.
So, thank you all of you,
for giving us your money.
And what we do is we say,
"That money's in trust to create joy.
"We have to turn that in
to the most joy possible."
And so, we look and we say for every show,
if a show cost a hundred million dollars,
how much joy, how much viewing
did it create amongst all of you?
If it cost fifty million,
or two hundred million,
of course, you want
different amounts of joy.
(laughing)
And so, we look at as
how much joy can we create of your money?
And if we turn it into joy effectively,
then you're happy and you tell
your friends, and we grow.
And then, we have more money
next year to turn into more joy.
So, we think of ourself like alchemists.
We take in money and out comes joy.
(laughing)
I would say I've always believed
that a strong mission
statement's really important
and I have to say we've never
succeeded at it. (laughing)
It's like this odd thing.
We've had them every year for 15 years
and they're constantly different
and now we're all so cynical.
We're like, "Come on, we're
trying to make people happy."
I mean, that's the fundamental
thing in consumer service.
We're trying to be
better and us and Disney
and Mission aren't that different.
There's a bunch of different tactics at it
but we're an emotional product.
We cater to the things that are important,
but not necessary and I
love that part about it
'cause like, when you you're
selling milk or penicillin,
you're selling something
that somebody needs.
And we get to sell
something you want, okay,
that you choose to do
because it's really cool.
It's human to be entertained
and to connect to people
over entertainment.
And so, we celebrate that a lot
and we want to change the industry.
But in terms of, like a mission statement
like so many companies have,
Facebook talks about a more
connected and open world.
And then, you see that phrase
again and again and again.
And it's a powerful mantra.
We don't have an equivalent.
And I think we probably
would've been stronger if we do.
In the early days, it was to connect
people with movies they'll love.
And it's okay, but it's kind of like
the long, kind of awkward phrase.
Connect people with movies they'll love.
It's just not punchy.
And then, so like, we used
it, we had t-shirts, you know.
And then, it didn't
really motivate anyone,
didn't really stick.
But we knew we were trying to
make people happy with DVDs.
And then, eventually it was
dreaming and original content.
So it didn't hold us back much.
- What I find interesting about you,
the way you conduct your business is that
when stuff doesn't work
out, you apologize.
You go out and say, "I made
a mistake," and all that.
What was that the first
time you had to go out there
and say, "Sorry, this was wrong."
And I remember the increase,
the rate increased, right?
And then you were like,
"Well, forget about it."
Like, what was that experience
like for you as a boss
when you're like, "I
have to go and own this."
- Going through marriage
counseling 20 years ago...
(audience laughing)
was really how I moved to become
a better manager and leader.
- [Host] Really?
- And yeah, you know,
this marriage counselor
was able to get me to see that I was often
lying to myself and to my wife.
You know, saying, "Oh family
is the most important thing."
And then I'd stay at work all night.
And that the value of honesty is
that people can take honesty,
even if it's not necessarily what they
want to hear, if it's really sincere.
- So then the question is Reed,
what do you do to not lose the culture
if you believe you've got
a great one, early on?
- Yeah, I mean one of
the most common questions
new employee ask is, "How
do we preserve the culture?"
And I say, "Well to preserve something,
"to pickle it, is the wrong solution.
"We're not trying to preserve the culture,
"we're trying to make it better.
"And it's materially better
than it was five years ago,"
and I'll cite a couple
of specific examples.
And then say, "Well, your job,
"in addition to doing your role,
"is to figure out how
do we get even better."
'Cause it's only when you
struggle to get better,
that you really keep it vital and alive.
So, you always have to be saying,
"Yeah it's pretty good culture,
"but I'm sure it can be better.
"How can we be better?"
And so, it's that struggle to
improve that keeps it fresh.
You know, we're pretty good
at movies and TV shows.
And so, the competition that we
worry about is the substitution.
Again, when people are
spending time on Snapchat,
or Facebook video, or
YouTube, it's not Netflix,
or some new app that isn't yet invented.
And so, in the long-term,
you have to believe
that movies and TV shows will be
sort of like the opera and the novel.
Pretty nichey businesses
and human entertainment
will have moved on to something new.
So, yeah, we're gettin' really
good at movies and TV shows,
we're in the beginning
of a great run on that.
But in the long-term,
there'll be substitutes.
There's substitutes for
everything that come up
and then, the ultimate challenge
for us is can we figure out that
or what that new form of entertainment is?
Is that VR, is it gaming, is it AR.
In '03 and '04 we're growing really fast.
'05, Blockbuster attacks.
And so, we thought we were very clever.
We came up with a number
of ways to counterattack.
And remember that
everybody's got every DVD
so you've got basically the same.
Blockbuster and us had
the same content offering,
'cause it's non-exclusive
licensing to get DVDs.
So, we could differentiate on our service.
Fulfillment levels were
99% and theirs were 89.
But that's like a really abstract
for a customer, you know,
thinking of signing up
doesn't mean anything, right?
And then, they discounted massively
so it's like half our price.
And so we were losing share.
So, we were struggling what to do about it
so we did three or four big efforts.
One is in the end of '05,
we added Netflix Friends,
which was our own social network.
And remember in '05, Facebook's
just on a few universities, okay.
So our own social network
amongst our members
and if you enabled each other,
you could see what each other
were renting and rating.
And we thought, "Wow,
the viral effects of this
"would be really powerful," et cetera.
We added ad sales.
Back in the day, it was
like Yahoo-type banners
and you could have, we
could have, we sold banners,
you know, above the choosing interface.
We added used DVD sales
on our site to consumers.
So, you know, of course we had some
excess DVDs from four years ago,
so we added an operation to
sell 'em for four bucks a pop.
And, it's a different logistics
but we added all that.
And we added Red Envelope Entertainment,
which was a group that we
brought in to buy DVDs,
buy films out of Sundance
and similar festivals
to then, publish them on
DVDs, so getting into content.
So, we did these four efforts
and each one was a dozen people,
15 people and made us feel great.
I mean, the employees loved 'em
because you know, here
was a tangible thing
that was not just 98% versus 89%.
Here was a thing that they
couldn't do or weren't doing
and was a differentiator, right?
And wasn't management so clever?
And we went through these
waves of battles in '06 and '07
and in the end, we won.
They ended up closing down
the their online thing
and two years later,
going completely bankrupt.
But we looked back and
none of those four efforts
made any contribution to our victory.
And one by one, we had closed
them down along the way.
Every single one of those four.
And so, in hindsight, we
realized, when attacked,
we should retreat to do the core better
and not try to broaden the
surface of attack, essentially.
And it was a great lesson for us of focus.
And so now when people say,
"Aren't you getting into news or sports?"
We're like, (claps) "Absolutely not!"
You know, and we're really
confident of our answer.
Like, movies and TV shows on
a global basis, enormous market.
And so, we're much less subject to
being prone to go off and
chase the shiny object
to try to have something on
a checklist to differentiate.
And to trust, and in hindsight if we had
just gone from like, 98% perfect to 99.9,
we would've done a lot
more for the business.
And you know, and it's hard work.
It's operational, logistics,
how to get DVDs not to break.
I mean, the amount of polycarbonate
analysis we had to do.
It's all this stuff.
We would've beaten Blockbuster
sooner than we did.
- But let's talk about values.
High performance, freedom
and responsibility, context not control.
These are obviously not mouthed.
It seems like that if you
want to do well at Netflix,
you have to subscribe to the values
and if you don't, you're out.
- Yeah, and the reason that
we publish our culture deck
is so that people can figure out
before they come to Netflix,
is this the right fit for them?
- But what's intriguing for me,
'cause you're a competitive guy is,
I looked at everything that you sent out
in the last five years
and I would like to think
that you've told me enough to
replicate Netflix, but no one can.
Why is that?
- You know, it's probably
a little like Starbucks.
Doesn't seem that hard to make coffee
and yet, one coffee chain
is amazing around the world.
So, there's a lot of heart
and passion that goes in it
that doesn't come across in the words.
It's the execution, it's
the people at Netflix.
You know, China's a very special place
and if you look at the big tech companies,
Apple's done very well,
Microsoft hasn't lost too much,
and Google's, you know, lost a lot.
So, there's quite a bit of variation
despite all three of those being
talented long-termed oriented companies.
And when you look at Apple,
one of the amazing things is
when they did the iPhone,
they negotiated and talked
and built relationships for six years
before the iPhone was
allowed to come to China.
So from 2005 to 2011.
And that took a lot of patience.
And now, that's one their largest markets
in the world for the iPhone.
And so, what we take away from that
is a sense of great patience.
So, it may be soon that
we have a license in China
or it may take a couple years,
but we're going to be very patient.
And we're looking forward to a time,
a decade or two decades from now
when the Chinese middle class will want
and embrace the kind of
content that we have.
(swooshes)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Luke asked me too.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me too profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why?
What change are you going
to make to your life
or your business after
watching this video?
Leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout out
to one of my TDS instructors here, Felipe.
Felipe, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book.
I hope you enjoy.
I love the picture that
you posted on Facebook
and yeah, enjoy the reading
over the holiday break, man.
So thank you guys so
much again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(swooshes)
- Up till 2002, all we
focused on was survival.
And then, once we got
public and were profitable
we started thinking, "Wow,
this thing might last."
And the cruelest irony would
be to not want to work there,
to let become a place
we didn't want to be.
And so, we tried to think through,
what do we really care about?
And we realized what we really care about
is working with incredible
people on hard problems
and that that was the essence.
So we should organize everything
around supporting that,
of working with just
incredibly talented people.
And so, that led us to
freedom and responsibility,
because incredible people
don't want to be micromanaged.
And the idea is that we manage through
setting context and letting people run.
You got to have the right
people, you got to reinforce
that with values, setting context about
what the company is trying to achieve.
But the idea is to build a system
where amazing amounts of
service improvement happen,
in the marketing, in the content,
in the technology, in the user interface,
without direct intervention of me.
And so, some companies operate by
the product genius at the top
and we all know these companies.
And this whole motif of, to be a great CEO
you've got to be the great product person
who really, you know, and
it's intoxicating and fun.
But you're building incredible amounts
of dependence on yourself and eventually,
how well I know how Turkish consumers
consume Netflix is not that well.
And so your much stronger, obviously,
building a distributed
set of great thinkers.
People know that but in
the past what they've done
is try to make everything a process.
They said, "Okay, I don't
want it to be a genius,
"so we're going to organize
a process for everything."
And at least once in a while you heard,
"We're going to dummyproof it.
"It's going to be such a
good process that anybody,"
this was the IBM thing.
And then, if you dummyproof the process,
you only get dummies to work
there to do the process.
And so, that's why we're
so opposed to that,
instead, so focused on
giving people great freedom.
Realizing there'll be mistakes,
but there'll be a lot of
positive achievement, too.
- [Interviewer] So can you
give some examples of that?
You talk about it generically
and it sounds great
but what are some specific examples.
- So, I take pride in making
as few decisions as possible,
as opposed to as many as possible.
And so, when something
significant changes in the content
or The House of Cards purchase.
Ted explained it.
It was a huge purchase at that time.
It was a half an hour conversation,
you know, we went back and forth.
I said, "Are you really sure?"
"It's a great bet."
"Yes, let's do it."
It wasn't like me reading the script,
and me meeting with Kevin
Spacey, and you know.
Or equivalent examples on the marketing,
or equivalent examples on the product
and the evolution there.
So, it's creating a sense of,
I want to make a difference
and I can make a difference.
And if that's what the
leader gets excited about,
is that other people
are making a difference,
and you've got the right people,
you got to be super demanding.
So, the one part is
freedom and responsibility,
the other part is a
high-performance culture
where we say adequate performance
gets a generous severance package.
And so, we look at, we say, we want to be
like a Major League baseball team.
And you know, you've only got
so many positions on the field
and if everyone is not
incredible at what they do,
then you're not going to win.
- [Interviewer] So you
turn over a lot of people.
- And so we turn over a lot of people.
We feel like we give people a fair shot
and you know, we hire pretty openly
and they know what they're getting into,
but we're looking for people who,
for whom freedom and responsibility works,
'cause they do incredible work.
- Is part of the interviewing process,
do you have essentially a culture check?
- Yes, but not like a checklist.
Culture's always something that we
interview for, of kind of curiosity.
It's easy to find people who say,
"Oh, I read the Netflix culture deck.
"I can love it, I really
want to be there."
What's harder is what are the main things
you disagree with and why?
And when we get a blank stare we're like,
"Okay, not really a
first principle thinker."
And when they say,
"Well, I thought the way
"that you didn't talk
about how to acculturate."
And you know, "If I'm not
great on day three, am I out?
"Or is there, do you
look at it like a athlete
"where it's over some time
period to prove yourself?
"And if so, what's that time period
"and why haven't you clarified that?"
Then we're like, "Oh yeah,
that's a good insight."
First principle thinker.
So, we're looking for
people who are curious,
typically self-confident,
and they're not, they're
questioning everything around them.